et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis londres avec len sport man
eurodéputés et membre du parti
conservateur c'est notre vu de
l'extérieur ce soit bonsoir lense forman
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france alors tout d'abord petite
question un peu humoristique et
provocatrice aujourd'hui est ce que vous
avez toujours un travail pour
l'interview j'ai toujours un très
bientôt 24 heures encore ok je suis
toujours employé en tant que député
européen et cela se terminera à lui
demain hu à 23h au royaume uni votre
état d'esprit ce soir extrêmement
dangereux
cela ne fait pas très longtemps que je
suis en politique j'ai commencé à
m'impliquer dans les politiques
européennes en 2019
la raison de mon application c'est que
le gouvernement se trouvait dans
l'ornière et n'arrive plus à avancer en
tant qu'homme d'affaires avec un peu
d'expérience
au total ce sujet je j'avais le
sentiment que je devais agir les limites
du possible pour faire avancer les
choses car l'investissement et causé
beaucoup de souffrances pour le revenu
il fallait que nous prenons position
pour avancer et je suis très heureux de
dire que mes collègues et moi ont réussi
à résoudre et cette situation notre
succès lors des élections européennes a
permis à bord et shenzhen de devenir un
autre dirigeant il a réussi à obtenir un
accord avec l'union européenne et nous
voici c'est un moment historique pour le
même mais aussi pour l'europe et je
pense que ce n'est pas l'histoire cela
sera un moment très positif
un homme son travail mais un homme
heureux est ce que vous êtes au confiant
en tous points pour l'avenir est ce que
pas de doute pour vous aucun l'âge d'or
prédit par boris johnson ça va être trop
cela ne va pas arriver du jour un dîner
je pense certainement que nous serons
pure ni sur le plus infecté dans du
goudron à conclure des accords d'une
conversion de monde entier je pense que
relativement court terme l'économie
roberto nicco espérer est que le reste
de l'europe a misé observée très
attentivement car si nous nous en
sortons bien et je pense que cela sera
le cas d'autres ce dur est peut-être
regarder laurelli ni peut-être que nous
devrions les élites n ont pas besoin
d'être dans l'union européenne
pour prospérer et je pense que l'union
va commencer à se détricoter nous
pourrons alors à bord les nouvelles
relations
oubliez le fédéralisme et les
dysfonctionnements de cette monnaie
unique peuvent pas fonctionner à la fois
pour l'allemagne et pour la grèce donc
le cap que prend une europe et à créer
des dangers du ressentiment même à
l'extrémisme l'union européenne doit se
réformer en profondeur
et pourtant elle refuse donc le brésil
sera peut-être le déclencheur d'une
nouvelle vague de coopération
aujourd'hui vous le dis quand vous vous
avez fait votre job
qu'est ce que vous attendez maintenant
de boris johnson puisque c'est à lui de
jouer il y aura longue période d'un an
de négociations ça peut tomber à droite
comme à gauche on ne sait pas trop ce
qui va advenir qu'est ce que vous vous
souhaitez
jusqu'à la fin de l'année pour négocier
un accord de deux commerces de libre
échange et j'espère que les deux parties
seront raisonnables et trouveront
quelque chose qui est dans l'intérêt de
tous je pense que cette année va être
intéressante car l'union européenne n'a
pas encore tout à fait réelle complexité
et au cours des mois à venir il va
falloir qu'elle compose avec et dans les
mois qui suivront cela il faudra qu'elle
comprenne qu elle s'accommode du trou
dans leur budget parce que l'eau réunit
et est le deuxième contributeur le plus
important du budget ils ne vont pas
vouloir au gré de fuir leurs dépenses
ces deux qu'ils auront en un gagner et
ensuite ils vont ils devoir se demander
si ils veulent punir le royaume uni
corab pour être parti ou coopérer et
d'ici la fin de l'année ils comprendront
qu'ils seraient dans leur bonne intérêt
d'avoir un bon accord de libre échange
un bon accord pour le royaume uni comme
pau l'union européenne la présidente de
la commission hier celui-là van der
leyen était plutôt conciliante on ne
sera jamais bien loin
c'est de bonne augure selon vos revenus
nous ne sommes pas très loin nous
restons européen des voisins et nous
voulons être de bons voisins
nous avons juste une approche différente
ne souhaitions pas être contrôlé par le
cor centralisée de l'union européenne où
nous voulions un peu d'indépendance et
nous considérons que les économies font
faire une leur section indépendante et
qu'elle travaille pour la propres
intérêts dans le cadre d'une démocratie
libre et s'agissant notamment de la
technologie le
des changements au 21ème siècle est très
différent du rythme du milieu du xxème
siècle à l'époque où de l'union
européenne a été créée ces démocraties
ne peuvent pas suivre ce rythme
donc je ne pense pas que l'organisation
seulement de l'union européenne permet
un fonctionnement correct
cela a très bien fonctionné pendant des
années mais le monde a changé et l'union
européenne et l'europe aussi vous l'avez
dit vous-même vous êtes un businessman
pour vous on a plus intérêt aujourd'hui
clairement devenir des partenaires ou ou
des concurrents finalement au winner to
be bop nous devons être un peu des deux
les huit prospère dans la concurrence la
concurrence engendre l'innovation permet
de rendre les produits et les services
enchères pour les consommateurs ce qui
est bon pour l'économie et la croissance
dont il doit y avoir une concurrence la
concurrence c'est bien et c'est l'un des
problèmes de l'europe
elle a toujours essayé d'être
protectionniste et le protectionnisme
ralenti en fait l'économie
c'est pourquoi l'économie de l'eurozone
a été l'une des économies
à la croissance la plus lente de la
planète nous devons être en concurrence
nous devons innover et 10 devant être
partenaires nous sommes dans un deuxième
économie mondialisée il faut travailler
par concert et c'est très positif
merci beaucoup lundi par malheur aux
députés membres du parti conservateur
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france